I'm gonna stay up here and introduce the
next segment and uh you will you will
excuse the fact that I can only have
Western references because that's where
I'm from but if Aaron was a rock star
here we have the gods of like music of
of the whole history of music like and
together make Jagger John Lennon and
Michael Jackson all together
we're gonna have on stage actually
Professor Ling chong won who used to be
principal private secretary to Lee Kuan
Yew himself and then was the head of the
Singapore civil service and you
understand what it means not only to
have him here in any case but for this
kind of Symposium he was there when
Singapore was designed he was there when
all of this prototyping and
experimenting and system thinking we're
talking about actually was at its
beginning and he's going to be
interviewed today by Charlotte McCann
who's been for a few years the southeast
Asia correspondent of The Economist and
will leave on Sunday to go back to
Washington DC so in a way this is her
last gift to us and a way to gather all
of she has felt in these years here in
Singapore and accumulated his experience
and is learning and interview uh Chong
Guan about it so it's going to be a
wonderful segment and I would like to
call you both on stage
thank you for that introduction Paola uh
it is such a treat for me to be here
today especially in my last week in
Singapore and to be interviewing you
um in your many years uh involved in
public service in Singapore
you witnessed the country become a a
peaceful prosperous country in fact you
helped to become a peaceful prosperous
country one of the the wealthiest in the
world
um so I think it's easy to forget
just how precarious Singapore's future
seemed to be when it became independent
in 1965 I mean it was a small country uh
in an often hostile region the the task
facing the Kuan Yew of of
ensuring the survival of the country
must have seemed Monumental right how
did he go about designing a nation in a
state that would not just survive but
Thrive right
well thanks very much Charlotte and
thank you very much Paulo for the for
the introduction I must
um I must say you know how did he go
about designing that was your question
um but quite frankly we didn't know what
I was doing I don't know what I was
doing but Aaron made sense of it all no
so when Aaron put one to seven oh I
didn't realize I've been doing such a
great
great job of design and Lee Kuan Yew was
the greatest designer of all and he
didn't know it either so
and I want to say that you know
Singapore Singapore is still a place
which is um you know where everything is
always precarious and vulnerable and
maybe there's one of big explanations uh
that you start off with this idea that
we we are small we are vulnerable and so
we have to figure things out and and and
do whatever makes the most sense I
wanted to say that when Singapore became
independent in 1965 it was an
independent features unplanned
unanticipated unwelcome
um but the priorities were very clear to
sleep on you
the priorities the the first priority of
all was jobs and then second was housing
third was education and interestingly
you know jobs is an immediate thing
housing maybe is a five-year thing and
education is a 10 or 15 or 20. yeah I
think so so so the span of of what he
was dreaming was already extended Beyond
just talking of of what the immediate
needs was so just as an illustration
about jobs
um and this was something we did all the
time in Singapore's a big challenge I
started in 1959 when we became
internally self-companying in 1965 we
became independent and and we're all on
our own 1967 when the British gave
withdrawal gave notice of withdrawal or
British military from Singapore which
accounted for 20 of Singapore GDP and 20
I think was employment so so
um so between Sleek on you and and the
people of Singapore you know what the
what fears and what the concerns were
sorry about jobs basically the decision
was that the solution or at least a big
part of the solution for creating jobs
was industrialization and that you know
if you get the factories in Singapore
you you create a lot of jobs in the
process
um and so you take the logic through you
know once you decide the jobs was the
major issue industrialization was the
way to to meet the challenge
um then you say what you call an
industrialization you know you you had
to prepare the land you had to prepare
the factories you had to prepare the
housing for the people who are going to
work in the factories you're going there
to give Recreation to the people who
live in the housing in that area because
at that time jurong was quite isolated
on the rest of Singapore it is not like
today where you can take the MRT to get
there and so you're creating a whole
Township which has to be in many ways
self-sufficient but you can build all
the factories and you now have to decide
who's going to invest your money and
their money in Singapore to build the
factories and to and to work things
through and the decision there was that
we need to get foreign investors to
Singapore and foreign investors they
don't only bring the capital and a
managerial capability but fundamentally
they bring markets the Singapore
government would have enough money to
set up a TV Factory but we wouldn't know
where to sell the TV sets to after we
produced the TV set when Sony sets up a
factory to produce TV sales they know
where to sell to so so it's very
important to to recognize that the
people who are going to invest in
Singapore are going to produce stuff
much much more than for the Singapore
Market they are here for the region they
are here for Asia and and you have to
create the conditions for them to be
willing to to um to reach their money in
investing in Singapore so so from
Silicon you he had to say so how does he
create a nation brand or trustworthiness
so people don't feel they're taking such
a big risk to to set up the factory in
Singapore
um how would they know that a Singapore
promises tax incentives it will be
carried through how do they know and
that that peace and security is going to
be maintained and that and there'll be
not the racial riots in Singapore
despite your multi-ethnic and
multi-religious Society
um how do they know uh that um that
they're not going to come to Singapore
and face strike after strike just like
for many of them they were facing in
their home countries and Singapore
introduced the idea of tripartism where
the government and the employers and the
uh and and the trade unions can sit at a
table and and discuss the issues on hand
so I want to say that um that just
looking at jobs it's a whole lot of of
different actions that have been brought
together and functioning together as a
in an integrated kind of way and just an
example of you can say design thinking
not
formally written in a paper but
certainly the way that you had to bring
these various elements together to get a
functioning hope and you spoke about Lee
Kuan yew's uh sort of long-term approach
to thinking right you'd think in in sort
of 5 10 15-year chunks right this is of
course something that Singapore
continues to do today as as Aaron was
discussing
to what extent has this long-term
approach to planning helped the
government you know manage uncertainty
and respond to shocks a few examples
would be great
I would say from League one use mind
um I'm sure he he was thinking of the
people's Action Party being
uh forming the government for an
indefinite period so when you think that
way every policy you bring in
you think in terms of the sustainability
of the policy you think in terms of
making a promise to the people or to the
investors and you're going to stick with
it and you're going to stick with it not
just for five years for the next January
election you're going to stick with it
for 10 years 20 years 30 years maybe 50
years which actually happened for the
pap so so once uh so all I want to say
is that once once your mind is set on
the basis of the people's action party
for example
um forming the government for an
indefinite period into the future you
begin to be very
careful a very specific about the
practices and the policies you introduce
because sustainability
sustainably all the time at the back of
the mind because if you want to maintain
um sort of trust in the government and
Trust in the people of Singapore
you're making a promise to people who
invest here you're making a promise to
the people who who come here to work in
Singapore you need to have policies
which show that that continuity and
obviously the policy is based on a
thinking right from the start that you
thinking
10 15 20 30 years down the road and you
feel that any promise that you make is a
promise that you can carry through for
next 30 Years or even 50 years
to think long term when you know you
keep on winning election after election
no but it's made that way right I mean
the reason you can win election after
election is because you had been
thinking long term right and you had
made policies which is sustainable in
the first place rather than you make a
policy we can win you the next election
and maybe that you can't you can't carry
through the next round and you're not to
uh you need a surprise not too unhappy
for the opposition to come in so that
people can forget about your past
promises and then you try again after
after the opposition has run the
government let's talk about out
experimentation in and prototyping you
know can you can you talk about how
important that has been to policy making
and implementation and then and then
just to pick up in a point that Aaron
made in the in the earlier presentation
you know he was saying we should have
more experimentation in policy making do
we have enough of it today
well
um well I know I must I must admit to
what Aaron says he's in the service I'm
no longer in he says it's necessary so I
agree with him
but just as an example
um I'll give the example of Education
um education obviously was put in as
something very important for Singapore
you have to uh it's not just academic
it's about it's about skills training
it's about expanding the polytechnics
and universities and so forth when
Singapore became independent uh I would
I would term that as as survival driven
education uh you are very clear you open
school places in order to give
young people
um school
um
schooling which which helps them to get
a job which gives them the basic skills
upon which to build their future careers
but it's very survival driven you know
that that the subjects you teach the
emphasis you make is all about whatever
is necessary for Singapore to survive
and whatever is necessary to give just
just a start or at least a job to the
people who are coming to um to school
and getting educated I think Mrs League
one you once made a point to sort of say
that you know it's one thing for people
to be rioting or going on strike in the
streets it's quite terrible when
educated people are are the ones in the
street that that
and that's a big challenge
um but you know an interesting happened
um uh happened because Dr go King 3 who
was a minister of finance and he became
minister of of Defense before I became
minister of Education when he was
Minister of Defense he was trying by the
fact that um you know there are people
who came out from the schools who are
doing national service in Singapore who
were literate neither English in English
nor in Chinese
and so in Singapore Armed Forces we had
to set up what they call Hawkins
speaking platoons as you know Hawken is
the most prevalent Chinese dialect in
Singapore and because these people were
literally neither English nor in Chinese
Dr go decided he better set up this
Hawkins speaking platoons because if you
are going to train your soldiers to
handle weapons you better at least teach
them in a language they understand
seems sensible yeah seems sensible but
after that experience when he went back
to the minster of Education when he was
made minister of Education he was
determined that he has to stop this
problem of Hawkins breaking platoons he
has to get get people through the system
so that they get they get proper uh you
know instruction in English or in
Chinese or Malay or Tamil
whatever the ethnic background is
um
and then you have faced with this um
you know issue of resources whether it
is in terms of school places or more
particularly in terms of teachers and so
I would say that Singapore education
system moved to next phase which I would
call efficiency driven efficiency driven
in the sense of saying you think into
account the resource constraint that you
have but do the best possible job to
produce the students who are at least
literate in English literate in Chinese
um and and and until in that sense it
was efficiency Dr go even uh introduced
something he called teacher proof
materials you know so because you
expanded your school places so much
quite obviously if you expand the school
places and you want to have and be able
to accommodate so many more students the
quality of the teachers that you recruit
must go down
that's just a natural outcome so if the
quality of teachers go down what do you
do to maintain the quality of the
instruction and to maintain that he
produced we we created this this
curriculum development Institute of
Singapore to produce teacher-proof
material in other words there are
handbooks you produce for teachers such
that it is not dependent on the quality
of the teacher the teacher's job is to
make sure she reads the handbook very
carefully and deliver the lessons
according to what a handbook says she's
supposed to deliver and that way you
maintain the quality of Education with
less dependence on on the quality of the
teachers that's the face of why I call
called efficiency driven but obviously
when you run that and Doctor go
introduced the massive streaming system
in Singapore in order to to to have that
efficiency when you are short of
resources in terms of school places and
teachers at the same time let's admit it
what you do there is some is you don't
do well enough in terms of
um catering to differences in talents
and differences in abilities and
therefore you are not doing as good a
job as you can
um to help each child be the best he or
she can be
and so and so the education system gets
adjusted to what I call ability driven
um a lot more attention now being being
focused on on the child what the child
is capable of of being
and obviously to run such a system the
schools the teachers need to be given a
lot more flexibility to adjust according
to what what the quality of the students
are that they have and what the quality
of the teachers are that they have and
that's a phase in Singapore's education
system where you begin to have
Independent Schools autonomous schools
uh where where you have schools you know
you have the sports School separate from
the School of the Arts because they
begin to cater for different abilities
of students and that and that's where we
are today so so in terms of
experimentation I wouldn't think uh say
that education went through an
experimentation phase it was not an
experiment it was just that was the
system that was used however it's about
the openness of the mind it's about
doing this and looking to see what's
working and what's not and therefore
being a being willing to make the
adjustment process of trial and error
right it is it is trying an error right
looking ahead to the future you know
what do you think are the greatest
threats facing Singapore
well I would say uh I think it's a I
think it's a threat to Singapore in the
sense of you know Nations face the same
problem as companies
corporations face this problem which is
the threat that comes from success
itself that when you are successful
sometimes you begin to you begin to
believe that you are successful because
you have got
um you have discovered the secrets of
success
and the problem that you face there is
once you think you've discovered secrets
of success you've become very defensive
on what you have today
because you think that to take in any
other idea is to compromise on your
capacity to keep succeeding because
you've already found others or the
secrets of success that I think is is a
big threat and an unawareness that you
enter into this space you have where you
become pessimistic on any new idea that
comes because you think you make us
worse than the past since again we have
discovered the secrets of success so I
think there's a big danger companies
face this problem they think they
already know how how to make good money
and they reject the new idea that's
that's floating up Nations face the same
idea so so I think in the case the
Singapore
um we need to have the openness of mind
maybe you know like Aaron was talking to
be more experimental to be more willing
to take in ideas and see whether they
work or not rather than simply say
that's a different idea from what our
experience has been so we reject it
instead to say well you know let's let's
try it out and see and see how it works
out you need to be
aware
that that everything that you do is the
best that you are able to do at the
point you introduce things and you
introduce them but the environment
changes the public you are serving
changes the quality of the people that
you have to deliver on the services
changes the technology Available to You
changes so the worst thing you can do is
carry on with the practice
without fully realizing that that
practice was like that because there was
a state or knowledge and most
particularly that was the stage at which
you have the resources and the culture
to support that practice but the
environment changes and the big danger
is not to be aware that the environment
is changing and therefore you need to
keep not only adapting but really
innovating for the future I think I
think in the case of Singapore we need
to be a lot more
um a lot more
willing to create new possibilities and
new practices as opposed to react to it
that's there's a great tendency to react
you know if I knew what the the future
is like if I knew what would happen in
10 years from now or I can
imagine what would happen 10 years from
now then I know how to build a plan to
meet that requirement so it's reactive
mode
whereas what Aaron is describing about
complexity is you need to go more into a
creative mode where you're saying it's
not there nobody has seen it before
and that's right the courage to adapt
and to advance an idea about how to meet
the future very important because
adaptation tend to be let's improve on
what we now have
I think we need to become a lot better
in terms of creating something which
we've never had before and which maybe
nobody else
has ever done it before but that courage
and that willingness of mind to to try
and see where we can go with the idea
let's hear a little bit from the
audience we have a few questions that
have come in
do you recall any policy product or
service division implemented by the
government that you were unsure of at
the time but which yielded unexpected
positive results
you know there's one thing
um
you know a lot of people talk about
about traffic congestion right
um
you know in the really early days before
we have the MRP system
um there was this idea about how do you
control congestion in the city and those
were the days before we have this
electronic Road pricing system because
the technology was not available so at
that time we had it was very manual
system you know you have to display a
coupon unless you have at least four
persons in each car going through and
that these people were checking to make
sure that every car that goes through
the Gantry has at least four persons in
order to be entered at entering the city
free okay now the government therefore
had this idea to say well you know but
we have to cater for the people who
don't want to pay the fee to get into a
central business district so why don't
we build this huge car Parks so that the
people will drive
they drive their cars because they
really
you know uh you know they would die if
they don't drive okay
they drive into these huge car Parks you
know as you can see uh even at Dempsey a
Dempsey there's this huge bus Park that
was a huge car park uh just like with
these huge car Parks outside the
National Stadium all these were built
just outside the central business
district and the theory there is people
drive their car they park there at a
much cheaper rate than the coupon they
have to pay to get into a central
business district and if this shuttle
buses which will carry them into into a
central business district the Assumption
there being that people can't stand it
if they have the car they just have to
drive it in however they don't want to
pay for the coupon to go into a central
business industry they're parked in this
huge car park they get into the shuttle
buses to go to there then we discover
it's not like that the people are saying
if I'm going to jump into a bus anyway I
might still take the bus from my home
so the car Parks were not used actually
you know those of you who may know next
to Chancery Lane they got this this
Housing Development there that was
actually a huge car park it just ended
up with with um much of this car park
not being used but of course the
government didn't tell you it was a big
experiment failed you know we built all
these car parks and also empty no no no
we cleared the land it was used
temporarily as car Parks but now they're
used for housing and they're used for
useful it's okay you know so what you
want is a government that says no let's
see what happens and learn from it and
do a better thing with what we have the
courage to adapt and the courage to
admit when you're wrong two important
principles yeah but you don't need to
have a government go out and say I made
a big mistake thing apart into her that
I made a big mistake therefore next time
please vote me again because I made this
mistake and I told you about it yeah
laughs
okay
um
very unfortunately we're running out of
time so we'll have I think we'll do just
one more question and possibly the
hardest looking back from 2022 are you
still content with it with the initial
design of Singapore what would you
design differently
I think as I said you know everything
that we do bear in mind radio is the
best that we could do with the resources
that we had and we what we are capable
of imagining at a time so that very
often people ask you know if you were
there what would you have changed I
would say that I would not have changed
anything because we were trying the best
that we could at that point at that
point in time okay what do we need to
what do we need change going in the
future my view is this
but when you look at when simple became
independent what do you mean sleep one
you have to do
here the big political
challenge right he had to deal with the
Communist he had to deal with uh how do
you how do you maintain the the moral
and motivation of singaporeans despite
the fact that we suddenly have
Independence but in terms of the
specific things he had to do
I would say that it's not too difficult
to Define it right whether it's about
jobs it is housing for people it is
education for the children it is health
care but that was not an overriding
problem because the Singapore population
at that time was relatively Young
Transportation was not a big thing yet
later on became it became a big thing
what I'm trying to say is that uh when
you when you look at what you what the
government specifically had to produce
to the public I have no doubt that just
by dealing with the jobs issue and
housing issue
I have no problem imagining that 80 of
singaporeans will vote for the pap
and the reason is simple because we are
all
relatively equally poor
and we all appreciated the job then we
all appreciate their educational
opportunities and so forth but today is
different today today income levels have
gone up education levels have gone up
each person feels that he's got a better
idea on what to do so so I think we have
to think a lot more in terms like
already starting like like you have this
forum today I'm a lot more in terms of
how do we how how do we create what what
Aaron talk about
um uh you know convening meetings
convening meeting places or people
coming together
um and by convening itself is not good
enough again the word from Aaron you
need to aggregate the ideas because the
point you want to make is that
individual ideas on their own is very
difficult to support but if you can
bring the ideas together and and and put
them under a strategic umbrella we are
able to put budget behind it they are
able to put people behind but I would
say as a government now you can't just
you can't so easily say there are three
four or five priorities that we have to
deal with now you have to talk about
much multiplicity of which which is
multiplicity of ideas
and you have to create space for that
um but where I think singaporeans have
to get used to is it's not just about
well you know you give your view
everybody has a view and they say who's
going to act on it I say that's what I
give a view for the government to do the
things
I think the multiplicity of hopes and
wishes are so great that we all need to
be you know you talk agency we know we
all need to be a lot more active a lot
more willing to be involved in doing
stuff
rather than simply saying I voice The
View I voice my idea for the government
to deliver I think that has to change
but I think in the process of changing
we are going to be a lot stronger in the
past because you're going to have this
diversity of views we're going to learn
a lot more of how to integrate this
diversity so we get
a lot more of the totality of the
talents and abilities in Singapore than
we've ever been able to get in the past
that's my view thank you perfect note
and done
[Applause]